[Applause]
[Music]
dear viewer on fiscal policy I think
most of you will agree achieving a
strong democracy ain't an easy thing in
our worlds there are many democracies
but unfortunately really there aren't
that many high quality ones and
obviously when I'm talking about quality
here I mean it's a democratic system
that respects individual freedom legal
security political plurality you know
important things like that teaching
corneum authority no can be political in
any book as you know democracia poor oh
man well when it comes down to it
there's one basic principle that's
essential for any quality democracy and
it isn't usually liked by politicians
and here I'm talking about
Ulsan nations something that's essential
in order to stop any single person or
group of people from the essentially
taking over government institutions Joe
Cocker la democracia is not an ellipse a
respect on a leader tara las personas we
were taught we shown the movie end
oh yeah kisses Patty and Aladdin Chrissy
it's precisely due to this concern that
many countries have a limitation of
mandates nothing is as dangerous as
allowing the same citizen to stay in
power for a long time the people get
used to obeying him and him to leading
them from here usurpation and tyranny
emerge Seamon believe our folks trying
to prevent political alternation at any
cost isn't new or indeed rare throughout
the world and in recent years in one way
or another Latin America has been
plagued with politicians who've managed
to retain power at all costs politicians
like Daniel Ortega in Nicaragua horn
Orlando Hernandez in Honduras and
Nicolas Maduro in Venezuela now the
latest person to join this list seems to
be the Bolivian President Evo Morales
and the question many of you are
probably asking right now is is Bolivian
democracy actually in danger what
exactly is happening and why is ever
more Alice's candidacy so controversial
well listen up
[Music]
promises an addiction to power on
January the 22nd 2006 with more than 50%
of the vote ever morales became the
first indigenous president in the a
hundred and ninety three years that have
passed since Bolivia's independence his
arrival to power meant the end of
political exclusion for most of Bolivian
society in fact from a historical
perspective I think Morales is rise to
power it was sort of inevitable
[Music]
but with his leftist speech against
Yankee imperialism and in favor of the
political participation of indigenous
peoples in the nationalization of
Natural Resources ever Morales set out
to lead a transformation in the country
a transformation that had white popular
support to achieve his objectives the
Bolivian government opted for something
that has become very fashionable in
Latin America in recent years and that's
changing the Constitution something that
by the way also gained a lot of popular
support as election after election fo
morales swept the polls
[Music]
but let's get back to the Constitution
to ever Morales own Constitution this is
what his article 168 set the mandate of
the state's president or vice president
lasts for five years and they may be
reelected only once on a continuous
basis article 168 of the Bolivian
Constitution it's pretty clear right on
a continuous basis a person can only
exercise the office of president for two
turns and each term lasts five years
thus as Morales ran for re-election in
2009 his time in government should have
ended in 2014 rice I mean that's basic
mathematics
[Music]
just hold on a minute because something
doesn't fit it it's the year 2018 and
ever Morales is still in power and is
going to run for re-election in 2019 so
now the question in your mind is well
what the hell happens well listen up the
indefinite re-election
folks this is the story of how a man
fell in love with power so let's see a
Vosges Constitution established
alternation as a necessary principle in
order for democracy to work but as soon
as the new constitution was approved
problems began ever said okay the
previous mandate it didn't count because
you know that happened under a different
constitutions so just as the Bolivian
state had to be refounded they needed to
reset the score to 0 and yes it is as
absurd as it sounds alternation isn't a
punishment it's a way of preventing a
person from being in power for too long
and if you believe in it and introduce
it into the Constitution that you
yourself have promoted your kind of
should respect it right
well actually no in fact everywhere
allas managed to get a positive ruling
from the Constitutional Court on a very
controversial case according to the
court Morales had been the president of
Bolivia but now we wanted to become the
presidents of the pleura national state
of Bolivia which is not the same thing
so he could govern for two more
consecutive terms
see the difference well overnight
Bolivia the Bolivia that had always
existed had simply disappeared
this explains why he ran in the 2009
elections and again for re-election in
2014 but of course he wouldn't be able
to run again and actually Morales
himself has said this plenty of times
he said that in 2019 he's going to leave
the world of politics to open his own
restaurants but hold on a second because
uber alles yeah the restaurant sounded
really great but you know what else
sounded really great staying in power
[Music]
so yeah in 2015 just one year after his
reelection deputies are related to the
president's presented a proposal to
reform the Constitution theme newly
approved Constitution by the way and I'm
betting you can guess what they wanted
to do to it yes the change they wanted
to push through was that the president
could be reelected two times so that
yes Morales could run again in 2019
however this time the shot backfired the
reform did go ahead in Parliament but it
also had to be approved by referendum
and their rather surprisingly Morales
lost
[Music]
do you agree with the reform of article
168 of the political constitution of the
state so that the president and
vice-president of the state can be
reelected twice in a continuous way a
question of the 2016 Bolivian
constitutional referendum the question
was clear and the answers even more so
yes or no yes or no to re-election and
the Bolivians they said no but what do
you think Evo Morales did did he accept
the result of this referendum and the
Constitution that he himself had
embraced and promoted well no obviously
not
the indigenous leader the politician he
was going to return sovereignty to the
people he suddenly came and said
basically all right well the people in
the referendum they were basically
manipulated you know we don't need to
take them into account but really
despite of all this in spite of
everything he did promise to respect the
results and I ain't got to be wondering
well did he really and the answer was
well no see taking advantage of his
control over the institution's which is
precisely what alternation tries to
avoid Morales managed to do something
unheard of the pleura National
Constitutional Court that body tasked
with interpreting fundamental rule in
its 84 2017 ruling declared parts of the
Constitution itself as invalid to
justify such a measure they used
international law and the Constitutional
Court devoted itself to assessing and
interpreting the American Convention on
Human Rights the inter-american Court
jurisprudence everything but the
National Constitution itself
in the end the result of this entire
experiment was that the articles that
bothered Morales from his own
Constitution were de facto repealed and
it was ruled listen to this that
indefinite re-elections were a human
right this is because they interpreted
it is basically that limiting mandates
and demanding alternation is an
undermining of human rights mm-hmm in
short let's get serious because it's no
joke when a politician can undo whatever
he pleases with his country's
institutions this is something that's
incredibly dangerous the fact is that in
Bolivia article 168 hasn't been repealed
or modified what happens is that now the
Bolivian Constitution has parts that are
upheld and other parts that are not all
of this has unleashed protests against
Morales anti-democratic drift both
inside and outside of the country of
course in the face of such a spectacle
several members of the Electoral
Tribunal have resigned and have been
replaced by people close to Morales his
own party thus finally on December 4th
2018 this body approved even more
Alice's candidacy to the presidency and
Alvaro Garcia llanera to the vice
presidency nothing is as dangerous as
allowing the same citizen to stay in
power for a long time the people get
used to obeying him and him to leading
them from here usurpation and tyranny
emerge Seamon Bolivar but just a second
I know some of you might be thinking
right now you might be thinking well
hold on Simon they're still gonna be
election store right I mean if the
Bolivians don't want him then they
shouldn't voted for him right well folks
there are actually two problems with
this first a democracy never ever can
consist of tyranny of the majority over
the minority institutions need to be
respected and their mechanisms must
exist to prevent a politician from
clinging to power through the use of
techniques such as client holistic
voting dependence on the government's
control of the media fortress simple
coercion the second problem has a lot to
do with the obsession with power that
Morales has shown
[Music]
in other words how far ever Morales and
his party the movement to socialism
willing to go in order to stand power
[Music]
ever lost the referendum then distill
running he's moved heaven and earth just
to be a candidate again so now the
question is will he be willing to lose
the elections or will he opted instead
for the strategy of winning at any cost
I'm referring to the strategy this kept
people like Nicolas Maduro Daniel Ortega
and Juan Orlando Hernandez in power it's
kind of the usual move this is the
question that many are asking themselves
in Bolivia right now and watch out
because what Evo Morales has achieved
besides being the Bolivian politician
who's been in power the longest is
getting his country's institutions to
act on his will Bolivians protests on
mass against Evo Morales
illegal attempts to remain in power
anyway folks era visual politic will be
very very attentive to whatever may come
and we'll keep you posted so I really
hope you enjoyed this video please do
hit that like button if you did and
don't forget to subscribe for brand new
videos several days a week also don't
forget to check out our friends at the
rican to the media podcast they provided
the vocals in this episode but we're not
mine also this channel is possible
because of patreon and our patrons on
that platform please consider joining
them and supporting our mission of
providing independent political coverage
and as always i'll see in the next video
[Music]